all right here we go smart looking
looking for tatum gets it in tatum
takes it makes it
[Applause]
no question look at this shot i mean no
space to work
the game of three it wasn't two
but look at jason tatum waste no time at
[Music]
all
tatum drives george right there tatum
gets a wide open look
and knocks it down jason tatum ties the
game
well the inbounder is grant williams who
they trust
late game so marcus smart just hands off
[Applause]
i don't i didn't i wouldn't mind seeing
that again like they're making that live
it looks to me initially like their feet
get tangled
that's exactly what happens i mean paul
falls because their
feet get tangled what do you make of
what they've done since that time
well i thought the demand early on in
this answer these guys are legit
star players and
brad stevens is not afraid it was
interesting you'll be in looking at the
numbers
they have only one win on the road
against an over 500 team
oh jason tatum bring that slow
this is just a great move i beat you on
my shoulder
the rotating man could not get there in
time and i'm going strong
i'm gonna use my forearms first field
goal the boston lead is down to two
[Music]
tatum on the drive oh he puts it
oh young lost the dribble as he tried to
put him over their
what a beautiful play i believe that was
tatum with the pass there
here's this deal by tatum and the this
you are correct it is jason tatum with a
gorgeous pass
tatum
under six tatum throwing it down
that's why you in the half michael holly
and tommy have the halftime show next
you might think he'll be shooting every
time he touched it nance picks it off
ahead to sexton drives to the basket
great block